bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va tester
une montre connecté on parle beaucoup de
smartphones là pour le coup c'est
l'occasion de parler d'autre chose de
produits connectés on utilise beaucoup
de sparte watch je sais pas si vous en
avez une
moi j'en ai ici et il est effectivement
c'est de pouvoir voir comment ces
smartphones watch peuvent nous aider
et s'il présente un peu de nouveaux
produits que l'on s'intéresse à un
produit anti ya pas très longtemps c'est
la masse fit stratos dans cette vidéo on
va l'ouvrir on va regarder comment elle
est faite on va la prendre en faire un
homme boxing et dans une prochaine vidéo
on fera un test un petit peu plus
complet et je donnerai mon sentiment
après plusieurs jours d'utilisation
parce que là effectivement environ en
lamé d'empoigné joya où elle est belle
si elle est belle on va voir où elle est
belle c'est génial je suis content mais
au final je pourrais pas vous dire si
elle est vraiment bien si elle vous rend
service et comment elles se situent par
rapport aux autres mondes connectés
donc on va regarder c'est celle là elles
veulent courir ou non au liban
ça c'est un joli bébé la base fit
stratos multisports gps smartwatch quand
on m'a proposé la tester je me suis dit
why not
aujourd hui tout de suite c'est pas une
vidéo sponsorisés mais néanmoins on m'a
dit est ce que aurélien ça t'intéresse
de tester cette montre connectée est ce
que tu penses qu'ils aient un sens par
rapport à deux communautés
ça me paraît assez logique vu qu'on
parle de technologie de nouvelles
technologies même si on parle
aujourd'hui beaucoup de smartphones
il ya beaucoup de choses dans le monde
de la high tech donc on va essayer de
diversifier un petit peu l'offre et
paraît de plus en plus de choses
alors on va parler un petit peu de cette
montre en quoi est ce que cette
smartwatch est cool c'est dur à dire ce
marc droite
en quoi est ce que cette star iii qui
coule elle est fabriquée par wam ilab
wamy fabrique tous les objets les
horaires et veulent de xiaomi et shiomi
et au capital de wang donc quand on fait
un joli raccourci comme je le fais on va
dire que c'est la montre xiaomi wamy
hamas vite stratos soit la somme en
espèces deux bonds énormes ça permet un
petit peu de resituer c'est à la suite
stratos et scali cool oui ou non là vous
avez en bas des différents points qu'on
peut faire avec plusieurs types de
sports course marche à pied cyclisme
natation alpinistes rennes triathlon
tennis foot ce qui j'en passe et des
meilleurs il mesure forcément votre
fréquence cardiaque
il fait gps vous avez vos différentes
notifications sms appels notification
différentes applications pour les plus
sportifs d'entre nous il calcule votre
vo2max il est résistant à l'eau jusqu'à
50 mètres de profondeur vous pouvez
écouter de la musique en bluetooth et on
vous donne une autonomie entre 5 et 11
jours vous avez une appli smartphone
pour ios et pour android c'est une monde
qui est destiné aux états unis mais qui
est fabriqué en chine comme la plupart
des smartphones
elle vous permet de calculer votre nom
de pas la distance parcourue le nombre
de calories perdues lors d'un effort
votre rythme cardiaque la qualité de
votre sommeil et tutti quanti
voilà la bête on va l'ouvrir et on va
regarder comment elle est fichue à
l'intérieur est ce qu'elle est bien oui
ou non à quoi il ressemble lorsqu'on la
prend dans les mains et scali cool ici
ça va prendre un peu tout ce que vous
pouvez faire est ce que je vous ai donné
tout à l'heure comme information le
design est plutôt pas mal assez simple
dans le paquet et on voit effectivement
ce qui est inclus la boîte est quand
même pas mal je trouve le format sympa
elle est bien faite elle est sobre
classe efficace par l'intendant à hama
suite très clair très clean
ah ah
move beautiful pas mal du tout là je
dois reconnaître que lorsqu on our seas
et efficace et là bon il ya cette espèce
d'autocollants sur le dessus qui donne
un côté un peu cheap os on va l'enlever
et puis on va l'ouvrir si quelques
secondes pour voir un petit peu à quoi
elle ressemble la ca trù vraiment pas ma
réponse à un match ouvert ainsi quelques
petites secondes
on va regarder ce qu'il ya dans la boîte
alors il faut lever sa user's guide
comme ça vous avez toutes les
informations pour utiliser votre monde
connecté vous savez comment la connecter
vous savez comment la charge et ous avez
plein de choses à est plein
d'informations ça extraordinaire ici
votre chargeur que vous connecter
directement en usb
c'est marrant il ya un côté vraiment
très léger dans la boîte pour qu'on a on
a fait le tour commence à sousse ce truc
sans le h premier abord je la trouve
légère avec l'apple watch est quand même
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus longue
c'est une montre qui fait à peine 70
grammes vous avez un écran de 1,34
pouces avec une résolution de 320 pas
300 pixels c'est du lcd vous avez un
effet un peu carbone sur le côté c'est
uniquement les pas mal hein brasser
plastique je la trouve un petit peu
épaisse si je compare avec une watch je
la trouve un peu plus épaisse votre
bouton la vo de boutons sur le côté
lorsque vous mettez la pelouse avec le
bracelet en plastique j'ai toujours
tendance à m'arracher les poils et ça
fait mal là ça va ça va pas trop mal ça
fonctionne pas de souci pour lui mais
comment ça marche de s'appuyer dans
l'espace rien je laisse appuyer là il se
passe rien à ce qui se passe qu'est ce
que ça dit j'ai le joli à qui apparaît
pas mal du tout launching ap hm jusqu'à
le qr code
voilà j'ai l'application up j'autorise
lots il faut s'enregistrer et la voile
comme touhama speed sport swatch rentrer
vos informations personnelles votre date
de naissance je suis un homme votre
taille
allons-y gaiement votre peau a pas vous
le montrer mon poids je suis trop timide
votre avis
la stratos stratos plus fins et déjà
connectés donc là j'ai mon appli m'a
montré connecter mon activité toussa
toussa bon sens vers un peu plus tard
qu'un bras cela porte le bras gauche sur
une première prise en charge prouve que
la smart watch est plutôt pas mal
vous pouvez naviguer dans vos différents
modes ont tout ça on va le regarder plus
plus en détails font la prendre en main
de bien comprendre comment elle
fonctionne et puis je vous montrerai ça
lorsque j'en saurai davantage d'un point
de vue esthétique je trouve que ce gros
côté carbone c'est pas terrible terrible
de notre côté c'est très masculin si la
positionne à côté de mon appel aux âges
c'est sûr que la watch d'apple est un
peu plus fine le bracelet pas mal facile
à régler
c'est une honte qu'un tarif très
intéressant
l'irb est donc si elle vous intéresse je
vous invite à aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil je vous ai mis un lien dans la
description aujourd'hui on se marre et
et là c'est uniquement le boxing d'ici
quelques jours en faire un test beaucoup
beaucoup plus complet donc laissez moi
le temps de la garde et de la portée de
me balader avec de vous dire si elle est
bien si elle n'est pas bien si je me
repère par rapport à mes habitudes sur
mon appel watch comment est-ce qu'elle
fonctionne bon on peut l'appeler si
j'apprends correctement maintenant il ya
pas mal de choses à tester donc je le
rendez vous d'ici quelques jours pour le
test complet d'ici là restez connectés
abonnez vous mettez moi des jolies
pouces vos questions vos suggestions
tout ce que vous voulez directement
commentaires je me fera plaisir d'y
répondre
d'ici là soyez sages portez vous bien
vous embrasse et à bientôt
salon
[Musique]